okay stay with me here the board of
Representatives in the city of Stamford
Connecticut has voted to ban the use of
gender pronouns from its governing
rulebook that means people can't be
referred to as he or she in the city's
written rules don't be a bigger problems
in Connecticut one of those who proposed
the change is my guess Raven math earn
the state's first openly transgender
elected official welcome Raven it's
great to see you how are you doing good
thank you so much for having me
absolutely okay so get me up to speed on
the pronouns because in in New York you
have to use you can't use he or her or
she or him at all I guess you have to
use Z or her ze or hir or you can use
they or their and you can be fined if
you don't use the right pronoun in New
York you actually can be fined so you're
not quite there no you want to be honest
I'm not too up-to-date on New York
State's laws as I get my stuff happens
in Connecticut but really my goals here
my issues that we were trying to tackle
were simply the rules of the board we're
not looking to ban terminology quite the
opposite I think I lead the charge and
allowing people to use their pronouns I
don't want to tell someone no you can't
be a he and no you can't be she quite
the opposite use what makes you happy to
use what makes you feel right but you
require that people refer to you as now
when did you transition when was that so
I I don't like to use the word require I
prefer if someone else is going to use
gendered nouns for me that I don't like
I'm not gonna sit there and take offense
to it I mean there are bigger issues at
hand in this this issue what we were
doing is and I hesitate to even say we
because when I got on the board when I
was elected
yeah the first issues I wanted to tackle
were and we are tackling our issues of
development not being handled
responsibly in our city and these are
what are actually important yeah Raven
Raven you know I was thinking
I grew up in Connecticut and glastonbury
not too far it's a little bit of a drive
from but from you but Connecticut has
has so many problems yeah losing jobs oh
my godness taxes like I don't care if
you're transgender gay straight whatever
you are but if you're in politics in
Connecticut save Connecticut because
Connecticut is going down the tubes in
my view so when I read articles about
pronoun changes for the rule book and
Stanford are like my god I can't see my
face in the newspaper and laughing I I
think it's a little ridiculous to be
quite honest when I when I was elected
there were other members of the board we
were we were in the middle of reviewing
all of our rules there was yeah I want
to say something like 30 rule changes we
were doing I could be could be wrong
about that but there are quite a large
number of them and this was one proposed
by a couple of other people on the board
both Democrats and Republicans that
we're looking at and saying oh I guess
this doesn't really fit considering who
was just elected what can we do to make
the rules more appropriate so you
weren't even the real driving force
behind this there was some like it was
not good do good other members of the
board
that's wild given all the things that
Stanford and all the other towns and
cities in Connecticut face and that's
actually incredible like yeah it's gonna
be someone who just tries to work to fix
Stanford instead of focusing on pronouns
which it seems to me it seems to be that
you don't even really you're not really
even all that worked up about it what I
think what I think as funny as it keeps
being said oh that we're focusing on it
and meanwhile when we were at the border
at the January 2nd meeting of the board
of reps for the meeting last said I want
to say maybe an hour 45 or something
along those lines and there were a lot
of heated discussions there were there
are a lot of controversial topics that
were trying to tackle right now and this
was a tiny little asterisk next to it
yeah hang oh we got a transgender
elected official and now the rules match
as well okay well we appreciate your
joining us we wish you the best of luck
thank you so much all right absolutely
in